do you remember when Yelich was on the
show and he gave a shout-out to Yelich
to tell him el animal and the caballo
say hello yes we'll see the animal or
the caballo cuz Marisnick is one of them
and I just don't know Alex Bregman is
the other maybe he'll help us out with
that from the Houston Astros all-star
Alex Bregman here on the Rich Eisen show
do I see how do I refer to you Alex
caballo the caballo
Jake the animal okay you at the out
pardon me I didn't have the accent
proper the animal and the caballo
so you're though you're the horse you're
the caballo and that one be on the
caballo but honestly I'd have to say
Yelich is the harmonica pal he's been
having an unbelievable year it's been
fun to watch yes sort of like the the
the horse and animal and human all
combined sort of like an a-rod portrait
on his wall or something like that right
actually I heard you I heard jelly's
putting one of those into his new house
you're good been great been great you
know we've been we've been winning a lot
of ballgames we have a good winning
streak going on right now we got a lead
in our division I think it's seven and a
half games now so we've been playing
some good baseball that have a lot of
fun and it's good to almost be back to
full strength will get Correia back here
shortly and then it's uh then it's game
on for the post and it's not about how
you start how you finish I like that I
like it it's it's a cliche but I
appreciate it from you Alex Bregman I
appreciate it
so it just seems to me that across
baseball there's a you know tensions are
flaring it just seems like there's
there's there's there's not a lot of
people suffering too many fools gladly
and I saw you with the angels were going
at it a little bit recently would you
agree that this is the time of year
where where you're it's it's
temperatures are getting temperatures
getting hot and tempers are flaring
things are getting shorter fuses Alex oh
yeah fuses are definitely short this
time of year it's it's it's coming down
it's coming down to the wire and then
teams or teams are fighting to stay
alive in their plot in their respective
playoff races we're we're we're playing
the game hard we're playing the game the
right way
we like when things are handled the
right way and yeah that's that's what I
got on that whole thing you're talking
about animal taking the one in between
in between his shoulder blades right
there your manager was pissed and I'll
tell you what it's very rare to see pool
halls barking it I don't know Oh Alex
well we have we have a lot of we have a
lot of respect for those guys but I
think there's I think there's a few
things that has changed in the game the
game used to be him to get the players
used to handle that stuff and it used to
be done in the right way and um I think
Jake would have got hit in the butt and
there wasn't them and it would have been
over with and moved on and instead that
teams have to try and disguise that
they're hitting people so they're gonna
throw sliders and then and then hit him
up by the neck so we didn't we didn't
like that but at the end of the day um
at the end of the day we're we're gonna
playoff race we don't want our guys to
get hurt throughout this whole thing we
want to we want to make sure that we're
healthy going into the postseason
because I think we have bigger things to
worry about than that so I'm gonna bring
this up with you I brought out with your
fellow all-star of Lindh or the other
day when when something like this
happens and the bullpen runs in and
these guys you know they jog in they
take they it takes forever to get in
it's like 300 feet I think they should
just stay out there and fight each other
right by the door of the bullpen what's
the point of running in Alex great point
I don't know I don't know the rules on
that whole thing cause I've never been
in the bullpen right I never I never
know like what the what the rules are
for a bullpen during when the fence is
clear so I don't I never do it's like
what happens if like they're all running
in and one of the full-time guys trips
another one they're like it I think
there would be some funny stuff if
you're gonna fight each other I mean
you're you're basically next door right
it's it's like if you don't have a
problem with your neighbor and you'd
like let's go run 300 feet and fight it
out like it makes no sense to me Alex
yeah I don't understand that I don't
understand that part either but I do
know that
on the team better be out there having
an Avenue boys bag
that's what Lindor said he said that it
means something to him to see like the
middle relievers standing right there in
the middle of everything and I'm like
well all they do is just honestly it's
not like a 40-yard they looked like me
running the 40 you know it's not very
fast
catcher ease in his gear makes no sense
well I think I think part of the reason
that they run in is to get loose just in
case of God in the brawl gets thrown out
of the game that way they'll be they'll
be loose enough to to go warm up and
start throwing right okay Alex Bregman
here on the Rich Eisen show hey man I'm
watching the all-star game home run
derby and your reaction when you join
the ESPN crew afterwards did you retire
on the spot from the home run derby did
I see that right was questioning I was
questioning retirement but then again I
also know but that the all-star game may
come to Houston at some point so I don't
want to I don't want to fully retire
because I know that those Crawford boxes
are 315 feet away mm-hmm well yeah I
know you're a football guy too so you
know I mean far I've retired came out I
mean people do that all the time
but okay good I'm in the clear okay
clear absolutely but it's just again it
just seems to me just you know you hear
you're at somewhat of a disadvantage
when somebody of like say Vlad junior
size comes up and starts cranking these
these babies out of the yard Alex yeah
when I'm at the plate I think I'm six
four but in the home run derby yeah you
can think you're six for all you want
but you're not so the whole extra time
thing with the with the hitting a ball
440 a little bit of a disadvantage but
it's been fun competing in that the last
few years
joc pederson put on an absolute show it
was amazing yeah jock and and Vlad
junior who is that was incredible to
watch that have been one of the better
round two to the home run derby I've
ever seen that was amazing I mean that
was just so much fun when you know he's
got a he's got to hit an absurd number
of home runs joc pederson and he
actually went ahead and gave you hope
and then
we did it and then they went to two
overtimes that was great Alex there I'm
sitting there watching it with I'm
sitting there watching it with Kleiber
Torres from the Yankees and they're all
dis Chapman from the Yankees and Gary
Sanchez and we're all talking I say hey
guys I hate to say this but I think
Jack's gonna tie him and they're gonna
go into extra time and Vlad junior heard
me say it so as soon as he did they all
gave me a look like what's going on I
said oh I said oh no don't worry you
guys are gonna try again this next round
no you didn't they went out tied again
they'll all look at me Vlad junior said
bro I'm so tired if you if you say
anything else keep it to yourself I'm
telling us anymore you're bad luck
you're jinxing us so he went out and
ended up winning that round and he was
like thank God he's like no more talking
the rest of the time because whatever
you're saying is coming true yeah that
was I mean that really was amazing so
it's cool you hang with Yankees huh Alex
is that for your dad cuz I know you told
me once upon a time your dad's a Yankee
fan was that for you my mom's the Yankee
my dad hate my dad hates the Yankees my
mom my mom grew up a Yankee fan she's
from Long Island right she she grew up
loving theater idolizing idolizing the
Yankees as a kid so um now we get a now
we gotta fight it out with them for a UH
ALCS that's right now I bring it back
because that was your mom on jeater
night you personally ruined you tonight
in Yankee Stadium
you personally dismantled it so and you
made your mom disappointed and I know
you're a good guy you don't really want
to do that so why'd you do it well my
mom this is this is why I did it to be
honest with you tonight my mom's wearing
my Jersey in our family section okay but
she has Derek Jeter's Jersey on
underneath it so I'm like mom like
what's gonna happen like I go over for
you take my shirt you take my Jersey off
and just wear the cheater one because
you're embarrassed like what's going on
here what are you gonna do so we had to
do something okay
and you had to just keep homering I
understand you just had to go to just
yard right first inning that's totally
destroy it
that's okay you're a competitor you're a
competitor that's why you are who you
are Alex Bregman
so what's nicer before I let you go but
what's nicer the Astros locker room or
LSU football's newest locker room
it's nice oh well LSU football news
locker room is ridiculous right
hopefully hopefully that hopefully that
locker room helps us get a quarterback
because that's been the missing
ingredient for the last few years so
hopefully Joe burrows leads us to a
national championship for the guy they
bring in after him does I mean it looks
like a first-class cabin it's absurd
it's absurd it is absurd is there any
Bregman dollars in there I mean did you
give a little bit something no nothing
and nothing to the football nothing to
the football program if you see a
baseball locker room like that one day
maybe ok very good by the way we had
Tariq Owen on the show recently Alex yes
he is that Chicago Bears and I asked him
how many Jewish people think he's really
Jewish and he said all of them and then
said that he was bar Mitzvahed and I'm
like what are you talking about and he
said that a bleacher report Adam Lefko
took him to a deli and had a and had a
Makita sandwich and bar Mitzvahed him
that's absurd no way that's absurd right
Alex I mean that's that's positively
absurd right cuz I was I was bar
Mitzvahed when I was 13 no kidding how
was that for you walk me through the
Bregman Bar Mitzvah
Alex was well I had a weird Torah
portion and it was talking about like
skin disorders and stuff like that but
somehow I type that into mmm doing well
in the community and helping people out
immediately so that was interesting
especially at 13 years old to have to
read about all that stuff in front of a
large audience and there was a lot of
fun though no I got it got a giant party
my parents there for me at the house is
the first party and pretty much only
party in my high school life because
never really went to prom or anything so
that was the big deal at 13 and uh I
accidentally I dropped out a
confirmation class because I had
baseball tournaments all summer so
that's yeah now that's the way it works
are you can't have a candle lighting
ceremony where the person lighting
candles the waitress that brings you the
pastrami on rye like that's not the way
it works you know I mean oh no oh no you
got to do it the right way you got to do
it right then you
fantastic well done Alex Bregman thanks
for calling in I always enjoy our chats
we didn't really talk much baseball but
it's just seeing what's going on in your
life are you it's all good
are you ready for fantasy football are
you ready for the oh my god I can't wait
to defend my title and the Astros pop
out everyone everyone got mad everyone
got mad at because his team was coming
down it was coming down to the wire and
his two star players were on we're both
on byes so I said I had a I had a I had
a deep team ok they very deep my bench
was legit so I made a trade with him and
I acquired Antonio Brown and DeAndre
Hopkins but when they were both on five
weeks in the last week of the year
fake ends up losing and they came back
out five I won the league what are you
talking about there's two best players
are on byes and he had to win out so he
couldn't afford to go to the waiver wire
you had to make a move I knew I took
advantage of it and Malik look at you
gentlemen generally managing that
situation what's the name your team um
it changes every year okay what do you
hear last year it was Keyshawn Johnson
[Laughter]
what about this year I have to do
something like defending champ is gonna
it's gonna tie in being a defending
champion okay fantastic well if you need
any help or a commissioner ship or
whatever I'd be more than happy to dive
in with whatever you need Alex you know
how to reach me
you gotta keep keep breaking that's Alex
Bregman for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app